[Music]
hi guys i'm katie and i'm here with my
husband chris hey guys i do nothing
hey guys it's katie and i'm here with my
husband chris hey chris i don't know if
you know this but there's a huge viral
food trend going around it is jelly
island cakes
what
let me just show you okay
whoa what
aren't they crazy wait that is insane
looking so i'm gonna try to make one of
these okay but i'm gonna make it a
volcano island whoa with dry ice coming
out of it that sounds bold that's i i
would be very impressed i'm not scared i
must i'm scared oh god
we've got a leak it's all fine it's all
good oh
my god
i don't know what to do
okay to get started i have actually
already baked my cakes i have two eight
inch cakes and i have two six inch cakes
i'm going to be cutting
two inch holes into the center of the
cake i'm not going to cut the center out
of the other eight inch we're going to
leave that alone repeat that on my other
two six inch cakes
take a little bit of frosting and you're
going to put that on the bottom of the
springform pan and now we're going to
add our first 8 inch cake without the
hole next i'm going to take some
frosting and just smooth that over
the top
i'm gonna add some mango jam to our
filling it's a tropical island cake so i
think some mango jam would be fun
and it's just gonna add a nice bit of
color
next we're gonna flip over our other
eight-inch cake and set that right on
top and we're gonna do frosting and our
mango jam on top of this place one of
our six inches and just try to get that
where the all the holes are lining up oh
like i said i've never made this cake
before and i just realized that i'm
gonna be putting ganache around this i
don't i shouldn't have frosting here all
right that's all fixed we're just gonna
do one more layer of frosting and jam
all right we got a pretty good base here
the next thing we have to do is carpet
into a volcano i'm just nervous that i'm
not gonna get this angled right and then
there's no
going back
all right
here here we go i'm just gonna angle my
oh god
[Music]
all right i probably did not need to
chop as much off of the bottom as i did
next time
i wouldn't do that okay next we gotta
make some chocolate ganache so we'll
take our dark chocolate and we're gonna
add some super hot heavy cream
let that sit for one minute ganache
sounds really fancy but it's super easy
to make
[Music]
once we're finished mixing our ganache
we're going to take some and add it to
our leftover cake shaving use a fork to
kind of mesh all this stuff together
kind of like how you make cake pops but
instead of frosting we're using do not
now that that's come together
i have a four in shot glass i have
washed this so it's nice and clean and
we're gonna just put that into
our cakes
you can twist it down and then you'll
take some of the ganache cake mixture
pat it together with your fingers we're
going to build up
kind of a more natural looking mountain
here
now we'll spread the ganache all over
the cake and this is going to help seal
the cake away from the jello so when we
add the jelly around it it's not going
to seep into the cake so every inch of
this needs to be covered in ganache
[Music]
i made a mess but he's looking good i'm
going to go chill woof
i'm gonna go transfer this to the fridge
and let the ganache harden up a little
bit more before we move on to the next
step carefully
our ganache has set so next thing we're
gonna do is just paint
the sides of this with white chocolate
i've actually made some white chocolate
little seashells and
what's that a seahorse and i'm gonna put
some around so that they're under the
water and i'll do this for a couple more
spots around the cake
just to add some color and flair
next i'm going to take a little bit of
white gel food coloring and paint that
all around the tops this is just going
to add more texture and layers and help
give it that kind of realistic look
great the next thing we're going to do
is add the collar around the springform
pan set down some plastic wrap
i have some acetate paper here i'm gonna
spray it with some cooking spray this
way none of the jelly sticks to it set
it inside
trying not to touch the cake
tape these together and then i'm going
to take up the plastic wrap
and we're going to tape this this is in
case the jelly leaks
i'm going to set this off to the side
and we're going to make our jello for
the jello combine some gelatin some
sugar take some boiling hot water here
stir that until the gelatin and the
sugar has dissolved once your sugar and
your gelatin is dissolved add in one
teaspoon of an extract flavor of any
kind add some teal food coloring
i'm doing the quick set method so it has
some ice and water in here and we're
just gonna pour that in
stir until the ice dissolves
now we are going to spoon it into our
cake
this is the most nerve-wracking part
i've got to be honest
oh
we've got a leek we have
[Music]
katie
what are you
up to
oh you know just making volcano 2.0 oh
my god what
we have some problems we have
yeah some spillage
it's all fine it's all good
it's a new morning and um chris is here
for moral support hi
cause after several attempts yesterday
uh we found a lot of leakage and then
the structural integrity of the cake was
compromised because jelly seeped under
it but i made a new cake it looks
beautiful we're gonna add half of the
amount of jelly let that set and then
we're gonna add the rest of the jelly i
don't know how you guys did it all in
one time in the youtube world this is
how we're gonna do it all right you
ready chris yeah let's do this
i'm gonna also try to do it more
elegantly than yesterday oh that was
elegant knock on wood
filling up okay without too much coming
out the side oh god we have a little bit
but it's i i'm not faced i'm not phased
it's not too bad i'm just gonna ran it
more baby
you got this we're gonna get this in the
fridge fountain
set before it all leaked out and then
we'll do the rest okay bye
we're back it worked guys
it's it's solidified enough it's set and
i think we can just keep filling till
our hearts desire
that looks like an island it definitely
looks like an island to me let's get
this in the fridge careful careful
careful
while that jelly sets i've got some
crushed wafer vanilla cookies here i'm
gonna divide them into two bowls and
then we're gonna dye these two different
colors i have a moss green and i have a
leaf green this is gonna be our grass
terrain and then we've got some sand
let's move on to the next part
okay i've been kind of wanting to avoid
this part but the jelly looks like it's
set it's been four hours
so i'm going to take it off wish me luck
first we're just going to open
spring
springford
[Music]
you know what we got an indent it's not
oh
no
[Music]
chris oh
my god
[Music]
i don't know what to do you have to do
more gelatin
who's you
all right so today is my third attempt i
was able to salvage the cake i scraped
off the ganache put new ganache on it
and then i doubled the gelatin
in my mixture so that it's gonna really
really hold hopefully moment of truth
let's open this here we go
[Music]
okay i think that looks
pretty freaking cool so next i'm gonna
paint the base of this with some brown
food coloring gel
and that's just gonna add some more
texture and more dimension
next i'm gonna add little pieces of
plastic wrap
around the edges of the base i'm gonna
take those cookie crumbles that i dyed
green and i'm gonna use it to decorate
the top of the island to give it that
kind of grassy moss greenery
carefully remove
this
plastic wrap
i like it
all right so i think i'm gonna give it
him a little beach what's the best way
to do this i think with the spoon
[Music]
last thing we need to do is paint the
waves i'm using white gel food coloring
and i'm just gonna paint along the shore
and hope for the best
[Music]
okay i think that i'm done with the
waves this island is definitely getting
battered by waves from all directions is
that how the ocean works sure i'm gonna
clean up and then the last thing we have
to do is
make this volcano go off with a little
dry ice so
the show what is the finale the finale
is next
i've got the dry eyes
whoa
all right let's just start
with one guy going in and then we're
gonna add a little bit of water a little
bit of water
it looks so cool it looks amazing
jurassic park is my favorite movie and
now i feel like we're kind of on a
jurassic park
i think the only thing left to do is to
cut this cake
[Music]
let's taste because i had to add so much
gelatin if this actually tastes
any good
so the cake is good it goes good with
the mango the mango tastes really good
the jelly is a lot it's strong this is
the best thing i've ever seen
wow the peak of our marriage yep it's
all downhill from here that's all down
volcano
[Music]
you